well let's get Labor's view should we
Shadow International Trade secretary
Nick Thomas Simmons is here where
there's no hi hi good to join you always
um
the Prime Minister followed due process
well the Prime Minister has serious
questions now to answer we know from
Solari magnus's report that in July of
last year Mr zahar we declared on his
ministerial declaration that he was
under investigation by hmrc we also know
that in September of last year he paid
or came to a settlement rather with hmrc
that involved paying a penalty and yet
at the end of October the Prime Minister
actually put him in a very senior
position in his cabinet he must at the
very least have known about the
Declaration from the July the previous
July that Mr zahari was under
investigation so why on Earth did the
Prime Minister appoint him to cabinet at
that time and why by the way with the
penalty having been paid in September
did the Prime Minister preside over a
situation with that was not declared by
Mr zahawi until this month there are no
very serious questions this prime
minister who actually promised Integrity
he promised accountability but that
isn't what he is delivering instead he's
been weak he's vacillated and he's once
again put party before country he's also
an incredibly busy man we we are
basically at war in Europe we've got a
problem with the National Health Service
not enough beds at creeking Point we've
got a crisis as far as our economy is
concerned we've got an energy crisis you
can't be pouring through stuff like that
at bedtime
every single prime minister when they
appoint somebody to their cabinet has
that conversation and there's a process
that that has to be gone through for
that person to be appointed that would
have happened with Nadeem zahawi as it
would have happened with other
appointments to the cabinet this is a
prime minister who has claimed to put
ethics and standards at the very top of
his priority list but it's pretty clear
that that isn't the case and the Prime
Minister now must come out and tell us
openly what he knew when about Mr zahawi
and what he knew when Mr zahari was
appointed to his cabinet and also what
questions he asked of him before
appointing him to such a senior position
but if Mr zahawi was economical with the
actuality as far as the prime minister
is concerned that's not his fault
or we don't know the nature of the
conversation we do know from Solari
magnus's report that in the July Mr
zahari had declared that he was under
investigation by hmrc now that should
have been in itself a red flag to the
Prime Minister but nonetheless the prime
minister went on and made the
appointment to his cabinet the Prime
Minister should now be coming out and
giving us an explanation of these
matters the PM said he didn't know he
just didn't know until
um last week the city what the the
gravity of the situation are you
suggesting he's lying how could the
Prime Minister not have known about the
fact of the investigation when Mr zahar
we declared it in July which particular
aspect is the prime minister saying he
didn't know about which aspect is he
saying he did know about that's what the
Prime Minister has to come out now and
declare so are you saying he's lying
well I I don't know which bit the prime
minister is saying he didn't know about
it may be the prime minister is saying
he didn't know about the penalty until a
particular time in which case he should
tell us but it's inconceivable he didn't
know what was in the ministerial
declaration back in the July when he was
appointing Mr zahawi to Cabinet in
October but it could be a cock-up rather
than a cover-up
it could have just it could have just
slipped through the net
well I certainly don't rule out the fact
that the prime minister is utterly
incompetent that is true given that we
have frankly no Public Service anywhere
in a better State now than we have had
13 years ago the prime minister's
incompetence I certainly would accept
but this is also about probity it's
about ethics it's about integrity and
professionalism values the Prime
Minister claims to hidea to but clearly
has not done in this case he appointed
an Ethics advisor we didn't have one
he's got an Ethics advisor who is
independent so he says as soon as he
knew what was going on rather than just
um sack and Adam zahawi everybody is
entitled
um to a trial if you will
um and as a result he acted quickly as
soon as he got the report yesterday
morning around about seven o'clock he
sacked him within a matter of minutes
but with respect the for a simple
principle okay very simple that those
who are responsible for collecting our
taxes shouldn't at the same point be
seeking to avoid taxes it's pretty
simple you don't need an investigation
to come to a conclusion on that and
nearly two weeks ago now at Prime
Minister's questions the Prime Minister
actually said that the matter was closed
as far as he was concerned and all
questions had been answered that's what
he told the House of Commons of prime
minister's questions should have acted
then instead of vacillated for a couple
of weeks as he has what's should happen
to Nadine zahawi now well that's a
matter for him frankly in the
conservative party what concerns me is
the conduct of government we have a
government at the moment that is
completely consumed with its own
internal problems had a sense of Decay
on it is not doing the things it should
be to govern so this evening for example
in memorize a shadow International Trade
secretary I'll be hosting a trade
reception here in Westminster I'll have
over a hundred ambassadors and high
Commissioners I will have over 200
businesses putting them together so
providing a platform to create the
networks to open up trade markets around
the world that's what I'm doing to show
what a labor government could be like
the government that is the actually in
office as I'm afraid out of ideas and
falling apart talk to me about defense
I'm not sure who you've seen now Deborah
Haynes report this morning our army is
not in a good State according to a
senior General from the United States
how would labor fund the defense budget
differently well firstly what we've seen
is extraordinarily uh worrying and I
know it's a it's a sky investigation
that has brought this forward and it
really does now raise serious questions
about the conservatives party's ability
to keep our country safe now what would
labor do labor on our first day in
office would order a full defense and
Security review because our position is
that the armed services have to be utter
size to have a capability that matches
the nature of the threats we face that's
what we actually need we need to make
that assessment soon I know okay you've
been out to Ukraine recently we need to
be putting a long-term plan in place in
respect of Ukraine as well we've had a
cross-party consensus that's very
valuable and will continue about making
sure that Ukraine gets the assistance it
needs but it can't be on this ad hoc
short-term basis we also need to put in
a long-term plan to ensure that Putin
fails in Ukraine a simple question
I have more money for
across Public Services by growing the
economy that's what we will do big
enough at the moment would you be
providing more money and what sort of
percentage would you be offering three
percent well in respect of that we have
to make that assessment about what the
nature of the threats are and with
respect from opposition quite rightly
there's information that that shouldn't
be shared with us as an opposition
that's information that's made available
to government when we get into
government and we see that we will then
have that comprehensive review to look
at where those threats are and we'll
look at right across our armed services
whether it's on land sea or indeed air
and make sure that they are at the
capability at the level of Readiness
that they need to be and the money that
is required we will raise by growing the
economy which is why the conservatives
have failed so badly over the last 13
years okay and if more money is needed
from day one a labor government would
make that available a labor government
will put as its first priority keeping
our country safe and we will do what is
required for that okay it's good to see
you thank you